achterbahnfahren ist für diese
französinnen uncool
die haben den meisten spaß mit ihrem
handy aber mit einer virtual reality
brille könnte es doch wieder aufregend
sein
ich sehe schnee bedeckte bäume und leute
vor mir aber ich sehe euch mädels hier
nicht mehr
die achterbahn pegasus im europa park in
rust maximal 13 meter hoch nicht
schneller als 60 kilometer pro stunde
eine familien bahn und wer will fährt
mit einer daten brille durch völlig neue
welten alles schneller als spektakulärer
michael mack der chef des europa parks
er hat mehr als eine million euro
investiert um zwei seiner bahn mit
dieser technik auszustatten
sein gast heute ein vertreter eines
freizeitparks in brasilien er probiert
es hautnah aus und er soll das geschäft
dahinter verstehen statt
millionen-investitionen in neue bahnen
können alte einfach aufgepeppt werden
ein zusätzlicher kick im kopf das war
das größte aber häufig unter
funktioniert also auf viele gäste kommen
aus der bahn
herr matthias rohde überschlag die
abgemahnten angelogen da waren
überschlag brennen und dann bin ich
schon welche mit leuten zwei dreimal
gefahren
es wäre wirklich glaubt haben dass er
einen vorschlag japaner die virtual
reality brillen haben ein smartphone
eingebaut
das ist per bluetooth mit einem
schaltkasten unter dem sitz verbunden
so läuft der film im smartphone absolut
synchron zur position der bahn
der berater glaubt schon jetzt in ganz
südamerika wird sich das gut verkaufen
die virtuelle realität wird gerade ganz
groß dort
es gibt ja auch schon die augmented
reality dieses kleine pokémon spiel was
gerade so populär ist
jeder wird reingezogen diese technologie
wenn es so sein kann wie hier werden sie
es lieben hinter den freizeitpark steckt
das familienunternehmen mag ein
hersteller für achterbahn hardware also
schienen und gondeln doch jetzt das
geschäft mit der virtualität achterbahn
4.0 smartphone und brille zusammen für
etwa 800 euro gekauft 300 stück den
schaltkasten hat der technikchef selbst
entwickelt die 3d filme stammen von
einem spin off der uni kaiserslautern
das schwierigste filmsequenzen und reale
manchmal unebene bahnen zu
synchronisieren und schon hat er neue
visionen der gast könnt ihr doch auch in
der virtuellen realität handeln
irgendwie durch druck auf gegenstände
schießen und am ende ein punktesystem
haben und sehen okay ich habe jetzt 100
1000 punkte gesammelt oder noch weiter
gehen irgendwann wird es auch möglich
sein dass man dann auch die hände sieht
und dann mit den händen noch in der
verwaltung was macht objekte berühren
kann und die sammeln kann oder greifen
kann
einen großteil seines umsatzes macht der
chef mit dem verkauf seiner achterbahn
95 prozent exportiert er künftig auch
die virtual reality technologie und die
filme für 4000 vorhandene achterbahnen
weltweit steigt asien im allgemeinen
indien wird den nächsten ein freier
ankommen also stark asiatische märkte
und amerikanischen märkte
irgendwann so mack könnten die besucher
vielleicht unter tausenden filmen wählen
je nach geschmack science fiction flüge
horrortrips oder vielleicht
märchenwelten